depuis hier soir c'est le ibiza gates
sur les réseaux sociaux et dans tous les
médias les congés de jean michel
blanquer entre noël et jour de l'an
provoque une tempête médiatique
en cause une enquête de mediapart qui
révèle que le ministre de l'éducation
nationale jean michel blanquer aurait
annoncé le protocole sanitaire dans les
écoles alors qu'il était en pleine
vacances à ibiza
ce protocole tant décrié depuis la
rentrée de janvier par les
professionnels de l'éducation les
parents d'élèves qui appelle de nouveau
à la grève ce jeudi on tient le coup en
synchro mais là on en fait que du côté
de l'opposition dénonce une
irresponsabilité totale et un manque de
professionnalisme de certains appellent
même à la démission immédiate du
ministre je demande notre démission de
jean michel blanquer alors affaire jean
michel blanquer à evisa est ce qu'on en
fait trop
allez-vous type o car est ce qu'on en
fait trop non oui oui non oui non oui
non oui oui oui oui oui oui oui oui oui
bon jamaa barrette avec nos professeurs
d'histoire-géo merci benjamin toujours
un bonheur de vous recevoir
alors on va revenir sur la fair lady
révélations sur la sphère de quoi jean
michel blanquer et il accuse et gilles
verdez il est parti on va accuser de
quoi est-il voilà
au moins quatre jours en voyage d'amour
à ibiza donc loin sans être dans
l'illégalité parce qu'il est à moins de
deux heures de paris mais symboliquement
à ce qu'il soit 22 heures de paris à
deux heures de paris joignables en
permanence donc il n'était pas dans
l'illégalité matignon savait mais
n'avait pas validé mathilde on savait sa
revalidation sait plus avec jean michel
blanquer recèle l'elysée matignon la
boîte
c'est matignon donc le lieu où il ya le
premier ministre exactement que jean
castex exactement et donc il est revenu
et pendant qu'ils étaient là bas il a
accordé une interview au parisien pour
dévoiler le nouveau protocole qui fait
tant parler terre que depuis bizarre il
donne une interview ce qui est choquant
au moins symboliquement qu'est ce qu'on
sait de ses vacances deuxième question
on va vous faire les dix questions vais
boire vais tout savoir on sait quoi de
quatre jours avec sa compagne qui est
devenue sa femme c'est que j'aime
beaucoup oui absolument le week-end
dernier absolument c'était une sorte de
voyage de noces avant le mariage rich
media oui c'est une amie ben voila je
suis envoyé un petit mot que j'avais pas
mouillé pas suivi au bowling qui est
absolument ils ont fondu oui alors oui
il était chez des amis dans une maison
et les parties l'as bari et samarie
juste après le retour quelle belle
histoire très belle histoire
l'histoire
marié n'y avait pas énormément d'invités
mais ils sont partis là bas pour fêter
ça jean castex et au cou balma rien je
reviens c'est vrai que quand tony castex
samedi un [ __ ] c'est un peu le nom
d'une boîte aussi les gars vos casse
tête chinois
versement de montblanc caire ya
l'ambiance de vous fouillez donc et
docks et ben il a reconnu j'avais bien
donc il s'est marié il s'est marié
absolument mais oui donc on fait ce
qu'on avait interdit troisième question
est ce qu'on avait interdit à jean
michel blanquer de partir à ibiza et des
conseillers du roi alors il parait qu on
lui a dit que si oui alors le monde
révèle que le cabinet du premier
ministre et à déconseiller jean michel
blanquer air de partir à ibiza dans le
contexte d'explosion de la vague
domineront qui menaçait de désorganiser
le pays oui bien sûr et d'ailleurs son
cabinet n'était pas favorable à ce
départ et s'est obstiné il n'a pas
écouté encore une fois il n'est pas dans
l'illégalité mais il n'a écouté personne
ni son cabinet ni les politiques autour
de lui ce qui fait pas mal jaser l'amour
à temps il a ajouté que l'amour qu'il
ait omis jack jacques brel quand on n'a
que l'amour voilà voilà et nous voilà on
avait clos micro à souffrir en partage
le protocole sanitaire at il été
dévoilée tardy mois qu de ses vacances
lui répond que non que ça n'aurait rien
changé les enseignants ne sont pas
d'accord parce que effectivement c'est
son agenda qui a dicté sa ce n'est pas
parce qu'ils n'étaient pas là qu'il
n'était pas au travail c'est ce qui est
bien connecté est loin de ce qu'il se
passait le ministre travaille ce n'est
pas parce qu'il aurait été au bureau que
cela aurait changé les choses l'équipe
était là et de 8 en permanence en lien
avec le télétravail ça pose quand même
problème parce que ils étaient éloignées
au moment où il impose des mesures un
protocole qui gênent énormément de monde
il est très loin à minima cyril ça pose
un vrai problème à sémalens skis alors
jean michel blanquer retrouver va-t-il
ses vacances
regardez il a donc fallu attendre 15h et
les questions au gouvernement par la
réponse du ministre de l'éducation à la
polémique des les voir il a fait son mea
culpa en répondant sur la question dit
bizarre mais c'est vrai qu'en plus en
fait bizarre c'est ça c'est le problème
c'est
mieux mais il fallait éviter ibiza
saint-trop' et mykonos
c'est vrai voilà on l'a regardé parce
que j'avais le droit de prendre quelques
jours de congé après cette année est ce
que il y à des réunions ou des éléments
que je vais faire pendant cette période
que je n'ai pas fait à cause de ça
est-ce que non bien sûr et troisièmement
est ce que j'aurai les décisions
auraient été différentes si j'avais été
ailleurs non plus donc il y as je le
reconnais une symbolique il se trouve
que le lieu que j'ai choisi j'aurais dû
en choisir sans doute un autre la
symbolique
je la regrette mais pour le reste madame
la députée depuis deux ans avec la
majorité avec mes équipes avec tous les
professeurs de france nous tenons la
politique de l'école ouverte c'est cela
qui est l'essentiel et nous nous perdons
pas dans l'accessoire
est le choix
l'idée c'est pas de tirer sur une
ambulance à 3 ou alors que là ça
commence à faire beaucoup mais moi je
suis quand même très étonné on découvre
pas ici le quoi le 18 janvier 2022 ce
que cette la symbolique en politique ah
oui personne ne découvre ce que c'est
que la symbolique en politique c'est à
dire que là en réalité on en a ras la
cerise sur le gâteau d'une situation
globale qui est scandaleux c'est à dire
que depuis décembre on sait que le virus
va faire des dégâts considérables à
l'école il le sait jean michel blanquer
puisque de ce qu'on comprend quand il
annonce au gouvernement avant les
vacances qu' il appartient et miss a
visiblement on lui a déconseillé donc
tout le monde comprend très bien ce qui
se passe à la moi j'ai envie de vous
dire honnêtement si à l'école depuis le
3 janvier
les choses s'étaient bien déroulés c'est
à dire que les revendications des
personnels qui sont remontés par les
organisations syndicales avaient été
entendus si on avait faire l'effort sur
les capteurs de co2 sur les tueries de
l'intérieur sur les personnes aient reçu
un truc vendredi ou pain pour le monde
n'a rien reçu moi j'ai reçu j'ai des
collègues qui m'ont envoyé des photos je
vous jure la tête des masques on a reçu
c'est un truc de fou c'est bien
évidemment pas des ffp2 mais c'est même
pas des masques avec élastique c'est des
petites ficelles qu'il faut attacher
tant que vous n'avez pas reçu des
strings
toutes les photos que m'a envoyé les
collègues c'est en plus envoyer dans des
sacs poubelle ou nation j'ai mes photos
et donc en l'occurrence si tout s'était
bien déroulé mais je vous assure il
serait parti à bien plus qu il serait
parti à ibiza ou à saint tropez nous ce
qui nous qui aurait été important pour
nous c'est comment ça se serait déroulé
professionnellement ce qui se trouve que
c'est un bordel sans nom et quand et
donc on a eu le 13 janvier vous vous
souvenez de mon petit duo sympathique
avec madame et live et le 13 janvier on
a une journée de mobilisation massive
bas et derrière on apprend ça mais
comment voulez vous que ce ne soit pas
du point de vue chez les enseignants
quelque chose de totalement il ya une
attitude de scandale surtout que quand
même bon alors ça fait deux fois que
jean michel blanquer refait un mea culpa
quand on connaît le personnage ça fait
beaucoup ça veut dire que lui même
comprend bien que la situation est grave
mais ce qu'il dit en sortant avec un air
contrit sur le perron du ministère de
l'éducation nationale c'est complètement
insuffisant ils nous envoient quelques
quelques masques ffp2 bien du point de
vue des personnels il nous dit qu'il ne
dégage des moyens qui ne sont pas des
moyens pérennes c'est à dire en gros
c'est des moyens provisoires des
retraités à qui on demande quand même
dans des clusters c'est un peu périlleux
à qui on demande de venir faire des
remplacements des gens qui ne sont pas
encore formés faut juste rappeler que
depuis que monsieur blanc caire et
ministre de l'éducation nationale on à
supprimer 8000 postes d'enseignants dans
l'éducation nationale les faits sont
têtus pour revenir à ça et donc quand on
a à côté des enseignants qui continue à
être parmi les moins bien payés de l'
ocde et bien quand on apprend que
effectivement au lieu de bosser à fond
sur le protocole et ben ils étaient
encore jusqu'au 2 janvier avec ses tongs
à ibiza à excusez-nous ça pose problème
alors c'est du symbole certains vous
diront non il était en télétravail mais
c'est n'importe quoi on est dans le
symbole en politique et personne
n'ignore ce que c'est que le symbole en
politique c'est alors vous vous pensez
qu'on en fait trop valérie venez non
mais j'entends évidemment le symbole
c'est hyper important est évidemment que
le marketing en politique ça compte et
nous on parle ça compte et en
l'occurrence la veille d'une crise
majeure parce que la rentrée des classes
était là et que savoir après que que le
ministre de l'éducation nationale
étaient en lice a en plus la ville
elle-même est symbolique
énormément évidemment que ça va
réveiller les opposants et il a bien
compris ce que ce qui m'a ce qui
m'interpelle moi c'est que je suis
d'accord c'est une connerie je suis
d'accord c'est une boulette je suis
d'accord c'est une maladresse tout ce
qu'on veut après on peut croire ou pas
croire que ce que ce se munissent de
l'éducation est au front et travaille
bien ou pas bien chacun y verra ce qu'il
a envie d'y voir en revanche moi je
trouve que là pourquoi on en fait
beaucoup c'est parce que la campagne a
démarré et qu'on est en plein dans la
campagne voilà pour le coup il ya aussi
une opposition qui fait c'est un plan
car bashing parce qu'avec seymour qui a
défendu jean michel guy hoquet et c'est
une façon d'atteindre d'atteindre
d'atteindre le président qui n'est pas
encore candidat et comme justement le
président emmanuel macron quand il au
sérieux la faire selon mediapart le
comportement de jean michel bancaire et
ce retour tardif tardif de l'île d'ibiza
a provoqué de vives tensions au sein
même du gouvernement les enseignants ont
besoin d'être aimés alors que blanc
caire a quitté symboliquement son
ministère un collègue ma chronique de
jean michel blanquer remet emmanuel
macron préfère ne pas réagir et se tenir
à distance des polémiques l'elysée n'a
souhaité faire aucun commentaire mais la
semaine dernière en pleine tempête le
président avait remercié le ministre
pour jocistes je cite sa mobilisation
qui lui a renouvelé sa confiance
oui il faut être précis parce qu'il ya
une déclaration d' emmanuel macron ya
pas longtemps là si je pense que j'étais
il ya une dizaine de jours où il disait
ouvertement qu effectivement un
protocole sanitaire qui tombe le 2
janvier c'est totalement
ça laisse très peu de temps au rectorat
pour s'organiser disait-il quand on sait
qu'en fait eh ben le 2 janvier jean
michel blanquer est encore sur son lieu
de villégiature à ibiza forcément quand
même ça prend une connotation
particulière tout ça moi j'aimerais bien
voir effectivement une déclaration de
monsieur castex pour savoir vu qu'il
était au courant et qu'il a déconseillé
semble-t-il au ministre de l'éducation
de partir qu'est ce qu'ils pensent de ça
alors écoutez de ceux des infos que j'ai
ce serait même jean castex qui aurait
réservé les billets sur pageard
oui je suis complètement d'accord avec
vous monsieur amar je trouve que c'est
d'une désinvolture et d'un je m'en
foutisme absolument il est pas comme ça
en lui demandant comme ça non mais en
fait le problème c'est que tu ne rien
dans les poches en france et des
symboles nommé ibos mais le problème
c'est qu'on est dans une crise sanitaire
majeure c'est la rentrée qu'il ya eu 50
protocoles sanitaires à l'école que les
parents ils sont au bout du rouleau 4000
aux yeux qu'il a faim en connaissant
mais il le dit parce qu'on l'a ans là où
tu parce qu'on a dit qu'il était bizarre
aussi nom et trouve ça tout à fait
normal en fait d'être à ibiza alors
qu'on sait pas comment va se passer la
rentrée que les profs ils savent plus où
donner de la tête qu'on sait pas quel
protocole sanitaire on va on va
approuver ou pas donc je trouve que
c'est catastrophique et d'un point de
vue cynique pardon justement parce qu'on
est en campagne électorale mais je me
tiens à carreaux c'est le chouchou de
macron c'est le petit préféré je vais
aller à ibiza alors qu'on sait très bien
que ça peut être réparé fils tu devrais
devait ramener ça fait des castagnettes
erreur erreur politique majeure d'un
point du juste cilic par rapport à la
pac man est ensuite l'article qui est
payant alors que ça concerne tous les
français ça conserve les profs les
élèves et enfin et les parents je trouve
que c'est incroyable que l'article soit
soit payant voilà un mathieu je suis
désolé messieurs mais on sent quand même
se sont très bien passés d'un protocole
vous auriez râler parce que vous êtes
poincaré parce que vous êtes noir c'est
ça n'aurait rien changé vous râlez quoi
qu'il arrive donc s'annonce assez décidé
sans toit ni ses seuls
mots qui le
met à l'abri login ça fait 40 ans qu'on
est là on voit que vous dire moi au
moins les idées reçues comme ça oui
c'est vraiment ce que je déteste dans
cette émission chez eux mais en
l'occurrence parce qu'il fait partie
mais n'avaient rejeté que c'est un mec
bien
durant attendait deux hommages veux bien
qu'on fasse des scénarios catastrophes
et qu'on commence à s'imaginer des trucs
on a une situation factuelle on l'a on
analyse son analyse celle ci la
situation factuelle c'est effectivement
celle qui a poussé des dizaines de
milliers d'enseignants à se mobiliser
parce que rien ne va dans le protocole
sanitaire parce que et ça aussi c'est
factuel c'est pas c'est pas monsieur
amar parce qu'il a des lubies aller
regarder les moyennes les médianes
salariale de l' ocde la france est parmi
les pays parmi les plus ouverts
récemment attendait excusez moi pardon
excusez nous de juger l'ensemble les
conditions sanitaires dans lequel on
fait notre métier le fait qu'on soit si
mal payés tout ceci canton à monsieur
blanc car en face il est redevable de
cela il est le ministre de tutelle est
donc là tout on est en mobilisation
comme entretien cela et les paye on
apprend et on apprend qu'il est
effectivement le 2 convié encore à ibiza
alors que attend des excuses et que vous
n a rien à voir avec ces trois joueurs
et
il est ministre las pour le moment c'est
lui le ministre des négociations
salariales avec lui on en a plein il
nous explique que tout va très bien
qu'il a fait des efforts surtout ceux ci
on est mobilisée face à lui et en
l'occurrence est-ce que vous avez
regardé l'article sur le parisien il est
incroyable cet article parce qu'en plus
il ya une photo de monsieur blanc caire
comme s'il était un gros bureaux restent
alors justement attendait
justement qu'on va me dire quelque chose
y'a pas un problème on va revenir
sur cette affaire de ce qu'il a fait don
jeudi qu'il avait
encore une fois démontrer l'origine
d'infections plaie pour les années
spectateurs qui vont rejoindre qu'est ce
qui s'est passé parce qu'il avait fait
une interview dans le parisien il était
encore à ibiza absolument alors c'était
le samedi 1er janvier l'interview au
téléphone avec deux journalistes les
deux journaliste l'appelle il dit je
suis en famille ce qui paraît très
curieux c'est que la règle de base un
journaliste et demandez toujours où vous
êtes et qu'est ce que vous faites donc
l'exemple c'est pas du tout non mais
toutefois c'est la syrie voilà ça fait
quand une polémique le parisien n'a pas
su visiblement pas il était à ibiza ils
ont fait leur travail mais il savait pas
demander où vous êtes avec qui était
séparé connaissez pas les débats d'abord
pourquoi allez y donc ils ont également
pris une photo au coin d'une ancienne
interview en novembre et de novembre et
cette photo et son tapis ne mentionne
pas qu'il s'agit d'un document d'archivé
ne mentionne pas de date donc les gens
ont cru que c'était une photo dans le
bureau du ministre et qu'il pouvait être
dans son bureau donc ça fait un double
baby's à douala c'est pour ça que je
mentionnais le premier élément ça fait
deux éléments qui mettent aujourd'hui en
porte à faux tout le monde parce qu'on
se dise que le parisien n'aurait pas
caché la vérité le parisien dément avoir
caché la vérité rien à cacher la vérité
il aimante c'est ce que j'ai des
parisiens en fait ils n'ont pas demandé
où il était
ministre